cette feuille là elle devrait être
complètement verte et là on dirait une
feuille de tabac et elle est grillée
elle était brûlée par le soleil
le mal est fait pour les betteraves de
michel masson l'épisode de canicule
semble terminée alors quand il a appris
qu'il fallait arrêter d'arroser un jour
par semaine à partir de dimanche
il a relativisé cette nouvelle
interdiction heureusement ça arrive en
tardivement saison donc ça va moins
gênés pour l'irrigation des cultures
ce qu'on peut regretter c'est la prise
des décisions hâtives
le vendredi pour applications
le dimanche c'est quand même un peu
court pour prévenir les gens et
notamment les irrigants qui sont en cuma
ça désorganise tous leurs programmes
c'est quand même pas très sympathique
mais bon
on va on va s'en arranger cette nouvelle
mesure de restriction des usages de
l'eau concerne 150 agriculteurs dans 27
communes du gâtinais c'est de cette
rivière le fusain qui est partie
l'arrêté préfectoral son débit est
inférieur au seuil d alerte de 280
litres par seconde
les agriculteurs ne sont pas les seuls
concernés les particuliers aussi ils
n'ont pas le droit d'arroser leur
potager avant 20 heures ni de remplir
leur piscine
le non-respect des restrictions qui sont
fixées par arrêté préfectoral constitue
une contravention de 5e classe donc qui
est accompagné d'une amende qui peut
aller jusqu'à 1500 euros 3000 euros en
cas de récidive
et donc ces contraventions peuvent être
constatés à la fois par les forces de
l'ordre mais aussi la police municipale
les gardes champêtres et les lmr si le
débit du fusain ne remonte pas les
restrictions s'appliqueront plusieurs
jours par semaine